you know every chick you know they're
not cut out to be a good prostitute you
know what i mean some of them were just
hustlers
uh i train them to peel tricks like a
banana
fast money as soon as i step on the
concrete i'm catching a date for like
300 700 like it just all depends
actually i just recently got robbed for
eleven hundred dollars
you can spend all day with a [ __ ]
and soon as you ride a money and dope
she's going to next
i was with this one girl i said what do
you do
i do everything took me over to a spot
next thing i know my car got surrounded
it broke out the windows
ran into a fence it's doggy dog
i have a female chest developed through
hormones
and but i also have male genitals down
here
if you see the pattern of what's going
on there's several stages of evolution
and i will reach the end stage as a full
dragon when i have all my procedures
completed
i will be a genderless dragon that's
what dragons
are it is not expected
to go to youtube and amongst the options
to see
a picture of a man that has half his
face blown off
that's what happens when you go to a
particular channel
which is called soft white underbelly
soft white underbelly is produced by a
man called mark
later let me explain who mark later is
he was a photographer from the age of 14
but
moreover and more significantly uh he
grew up to be
a professional photographer working for
advertisers
of great renown and success so he's done
work for apple corporation
for bmw for ibm etc and the list goes on
the length of one's arm but he is also
the producer
of the youtube channel soft white
underbelly that features people in
america who are not often heard
although he maintains a studio in
manhattan and a studio
in los angeles he has worked extensively
in skid row
but he has also done work across america
in the 48 contiguous states
the show that he worked on was
originally called lower 48
and it produced a book which was called
created equal in fact he wrote two other
books c-s-e-a
and serpentine his most recent book but
most will know him
from his very disturbing and
impacting and incredibly effective
channel
again called soft white underbelly it is
my great pleasure to welcome to watching
america
mark later thank you um you started with
photography you tell us at the age
of 14. uh you grew up in chicago is that
correct
i was born in detroit but then at uh i
think 10 years old moved to chicago and
i still consider myself a chicago and
even though i've been living in l.a for
for decades now okay white sox or cubs
detroit tigers
okay i'm a tiger's friend but i love my
bears okay but what were your parents
like i always like to know people's
point of origin that's a great question
um
both my parents are lithuanian and my
mom was born in lithuania my dad
was born in chicago but then moved to
lithuania during like the depressed the
end of the depression
and then moved back to chicago or
actually moved back to detroit that's
where they
uh they met and uh had me and my sister
eventually and uh
you know we grew up in detroit and
chicago and i left chicago and moved to
l.a when i was 26 but my parents
uh my mom just passed away recently i'm
sorry they were they were married
forever
obviously and uh my dad's 91 i believe
now
so um you know my childhood
unlike a lot of the people i interviewed
was pretty great it wasn't perfect you
know
my dad and i butted heads a lot when i
was younger but but no longer
and uh my mom was like like i could
do no wrong in her eyes and that was
that to me is about as good as it gets
for for a kid
i'm not trying to compound your pain but
i remember when my mother died and i've
spoken to many people about the same
experience
one has this peculiar feeling of being
left on the planet
um they depart we remain and
it it causes us to look at things
differently have you found that to be
true
no honestly i'm ashamed to admit
i was super close with my mom very very
close and
she passed away uh at the very end of
january
and i honestly believe i've been burying
myself in this project which i which i
do anyway that's my nature
when i work i work like a maniac but
i've been so busy with this project that
i
almost haven't had time to grieve i
haven't allowed myself to
so it's like it's like i'm just
protecting myself from it
understand well you know that's that's a
a an interesting thing because
people in this realm who deal with it
counselors and what have you say there
is no right way to grieve we all do it
differently and
and and how we want to that doesn't mean
that that's any measure of your in
indifference as you say or lack of love
for your mother
it's your coping mechanism okay
well um at that momentous moment when
somebody placed a camera in your hands i
should explain that i'm also a
communications professor i teach
uh cinematography and filmmaking and
i've taught photography still
photography
and i always ask my students when was
the first time somebody placed a camera
in your hand now today of course
everyone has that as a phone
so all the kids today will have had it
do you remember when somebody placed a
camera in your hands for the first time
yeah as a kid i was always drawing and
painting that's all i did
and at one point i picked up a camera
my dad's 35 millimeter camera and i
started taking some photos
of of little like similar things to what
i did with my still life career
when i was an advertising photographer
like leaves and flowers and
animals and and i just took to it
instantly i just
loved photography i loved how it was
part a scientific document of whatever
you pointed your camera
at and then it could also be an artistic
interpretation of that
it was it was art but it was also
science at the same at the same time
and i loved that and i never put never
put the camera down ever again
so was it a progression of you know
going from a brownie
to a nikon a cannon to a leica i mean it
was no no
it was uh what was it i think it was a
cowaflex my dad's camera that i borrowed
and he just let me have it and then at
one point
this is one of the most important things
that ever happened to me
i had a cheap canon camera i think i
can't remember what kind of camera i had
but i was it was very clear that i was
serious about photography
and my my dad took me to helix camera
which is
the big camera store in chicago at the
time and
the other salesman is showing me the the
cheaper cameras the ae1 and the this
whatever and that's what i kind of
figured that that'll work
that does the trick for me yes and my
dad goes
you know he looked at all the whole
range and there was there was f1 which
was the
you know the the top of the line the
cadillac of canon cameras and they were
all the cheaper ones and i was happy
with the cheapest one
and my dad goes you're serious about
this right
sorry i get emotional
and i go yeah yeah he goes let's get the
f1
wow wow what a gift i mean in more ways
than one what a gift to have a father
with that insight
it makes you take it makes you respect
what you're doing it makes you take it
very seriously
yes and you put more belief
and energy behind it you take it
seriously
and that was that was that was a big
deal
do you think you were intended if one
has a sense of
of destiny you may not but do you think
you always somehow intended to be a
photographer
no no i just think it's what you're you
know i'm not big on that kind of
thinking i i just think you know i'm
very visual
i've always been very visual my mom was
very visual my mom and i are very
similar
and it just it just that's that's so
that's why i'm
wired and i could be wired to be a
mathematician or a
or whatever i mean i've always kind of
understood this on some level but i
heard
uh richard branson from virgin talking
about uh
career choices trying to figure out what
you want to do with your life and he
said
i'm paraphrasing but i think he said you
make four lists one is
everything you're good at make a list of
everything you're bad at make a list of
everything you love
and a fourth list of everything you hate
if you look at that list it'll tell you
exactly what what to do
and i realized especially with this
project with the software underbelly's
portraits and and
interviews i'm doing it's exactly that
well let's
let's start with that let's let's talk
about that uh specifically um one of the
things that
strikes me is that to do this kind of
work and i have to remind the
audience we have said this at the outset
i will say it now because it bears
repeating
at the outset of this program you heard
our senior producer
gina gamboni warn the audience that this
material may not be suitable for
everyone
some of you may think that we're
speaking strictly of children or
sensitive persons
we're speaking of adults too so we're
going to go into areas and territory
that many people might find
um unsettling and so we say that with
some forewarning
for those of you who may not want to go
where we are going to go
in this particular program mark you
uh have spoken just a little while ago
about the kind of distancing that you
need to do sometimes emotionally
you throw yourself into projects to be
able to get things done and to kind of
keep them
emotions at bay uh there's a curiosity
in
i think uh a similarity by you
having to take somewhat the same
approach to your work so just to remind
people just joining us i'm speaking with
mark later
he has a channel on youtube
which is very disturbing for some people
enlightening for others but hopefully
motivated
for the purpose of helping to change
society if not the lies depicted
then future generations he has
interviewed typically people in skid row
and elsewhere who
are prostitutes sex workers pimps
alcoholics people who are addicted to
heroin various forms of heroin
people who have been sexually abused
people who have been victimized
people with rather aberrant and unusual
views such as kkk
grand wizards um the array is far more
uh widespread than people might suspect
just looking
at just one hand of of the channel you
are dealing with people whose lives are
predominantly
for the most part wrecked how did you
start to come up with the idea of
inviting people into your studio
putting a light box up with soft
diffused lighting
shooting straight on and then from a
three-quarter angle from the side
and making these videos um i i've always
been
doing portraits i mean even when i was
like a teenager back in chicago i would
go down to the
uh chicago's equivalent of skid row in
los angeles um
the west side near west side of chicago
where you would have all the
the homeless alcoholics at the time just
sitting on the street
and it was it was fascinating you know
growing up in the suburbs and
and coming from a you know a
middle-class family where everything was
you know
our home life was normal and and you
know no traumatic events no craziness
and i would see these homeless guys and
i was just like wow this is what a
different world and i was fascinated by
it
and i would do portraits of them and and
throughout my career i kind of played
with
that i would do my advertising work
which was very slick and polished and
and i'm making you know iphones or or
computers or cars or cosmetics look
really great
but i always had this other side of me
that i loved which was
my fascination with these these darker
subjects and they're usually people
and create equal my first book was
exactly that i decided to go to every
state and
each each of the lower 48 states and and
do portraits of everything from
cowboys to astronauts to
uh polygamists to
repo men to everything you can imagine
you know and
so that that was that was the beginning
of of soft white underbelly
and so i i after self after create equal
it ended after that book was published
and
we had some shows and it was kind of
like okay let's close the door on that
i didn't know quite what my next move
would be with my personal work
advertising was still continuing i was
still going full bore with that but
my personal work i just didn't know
quite what to do and i thought you know
the skid row down in l.a is very
interesting and it's right here not too
far from where i live in my studio
in l.a and i got another studio just to
shoot portraits of people on skid row
and i did that for a while i did that
for years started in 2010. and
got some really interesting subjects but
they were just portraits and that's what
create equal is create equal is just a
portrait you don't get to hear the
person you don't get to hear their life
story you don't get to
know anything about them your
imagination can fill in those blanks but
but sometimes you're just guessing at
what the what the story is
and then at some point canon the canon
the
camera company came out with it with the
cameras that did video on
as well as still photography and i had
one of these cameras and i i just
started to shoot a
a video or two an interview of some of
the people that i was photographing that
i got to know
and i did an interview with a heroin
addict prostitute named caroline
and it was the most heartbreaking thing
ever like wow that was powerful
i just got lucky that first time i
thought and then i did a second one with
somebody else and the third and the
fourth and the fifth and i'm like jesus
there's a lot of interesting stories
here
and i should have just continued with
that
but i got divorced and just
my life got turned upside down a bit and
i put it down for a while
you turn the clock forward i'm currently
building a house and i had to put all my
furniture and
and my my all my belongings basically in
storage units i had four different
storage units across the city of la and
like why am i paying all this
rent uh storage unit rent
you know i i should get a one big
storage unit
store all my furniture in one place and
and maybe have a studio up front to
shoot and if that was
on a skid row that would be like killing
two birds with one stone
so i looked around and skid row and i
found a really great place it's right in
the middle of the action which is which
is good and bad
it's good in that people will walk right
by and feel very free to just like
step in for a moment make a little bit
of money and tell their story and they
free
they feel free to walk right out they
don't have to go upstairs they don't
have to go up an elevator
they don't feel trapped at all and uh i
started that
around march of 2019
and i enjoyed it so much i just kept
with it and it just kept going and kept
going it was like the more i did it the
more i enjoyed it the more i felt like i
was onto something
and i remember when i first started
putting the videos up on youtube i said
no
no one's going to watch this you know i
put them up on youtube just to kind of
show my friends have a way to show like
some
friends some crazy videos that i shot
and i thought literally
i'll get i'll get 20 or 30 people
subscribing to this craziness
and uh it grew and it grew and it grew
and mixing i know it
you know very quickly now i think it's
like a million
1.3 million now so it took off
you have been the recipient of some
criticism i'll mention the first one
uh and i i don't do this with glee but
just just to be
you know fair about the the issues
you've raised
um the first one is that in general
you're exploiting people you pay
uh people who are sleeping on the
sidewalk intense
20 or 40 dollars to get them to speak to
you people who evidently are slightly
more endangered by revealing who they
are because they have pimps controlling
them and what have have you
you'll pay as much as a hundred dollars
um no no
your your numbers are inaccurate but oh
okay all right well yeah what are you
actually
like a pimp is not gonna admit to human
trafficking on a
platform like youtube for for five
hundred dollars he's just not
he's not a fool okay so you know and and
a guy
who who frequents prostitutes and is
married is not going to come on my
channel and talk about exactly what he
does
for a little bit of money they're just
not it's going to cost a lot of money
are we talking k's here or hundreds
i don't want to give out my numbers but
it's a lot more than people anticipate
okay
imagine so the argument that the
argument that's made mark though is that
you're paying people to
uh divulge things about their life and
they sign a waiver
you've heard this before it's not new
and they sign a waiver of disclosure
and the argument that's made by some of
the little others who rally to you
to your defense i hasten to add um they
will say well you know he's just
benefiting from people talking about
their lord experiences
and people vicariously getting a thrill
out of hearing about other people's
misery
and there are others who as i've said
rally to your fence and said no he's
actually
conveying dignity to these people by
paying them and saying you know look
your time is valuable
um and i'm you could be turning a trick
in a car or in a tent or something
but i'm going to pay you for your time
uh as well
so how do you respond to the criticism
well there's a lot of things i could say
about that
one one is that
[Applause]
first let me let me preface the whole
thing with like you know is christmas
a celebration of the birth of jesus
christ or is it a marketing opportunity
for retailers
both it's both everything is both our
hotels exploiting the fact that you need
sleep tonight
they're exploiting you because you need
sleep tonight or they're just a nice
place to stay
so it really has a lot to do with your
perspective if you want to see somebody
is doing
something evil and dark then you can see
this as exploitive for sure
absolutely it's photography and
storytelling
but just the nature of those is is
exploitive it just is
there's no way to take a photo of
somebody you're exploiting a pretty girl
when you're putting her in a cosmetics
ad right and in turn i have to say that
someone could accuse us of exploiting
you
about exploiting other people
exploiting exploiting somebody is just
like it's it's
shelby lee adams is a photographer that
does uh portraits of
appalachian people or i think where he
grew up um he's a fine art photographer
you know he got accused of some similar
kind of things i heard him say once
the reason people will see this as
exploitive is because there's so
the majority of the people watching my
channel or looking at his work
are probably middle class or upper class
people and it's so
disconcerting so disturbing so un
unsettling to look at this stuff that
you want to blame somebody
right too much to process the human mind
can't go
wow this is really horrible this is
terrible this exists in our world
you the human mind can't process it all
so you want to blame somebody
and the easy target is the photographer
that shot it it's just
like there he is blame him he's
exploiting these people
end of story absolutely yeah and that's
that's that's a that's a
very knee-jerk simplistic reaction and i
get it
but the people that i interview every
single one of them virtually every
single one maybe
with a couple exceptions out of 2000
people i've interviewed
um love it and they want to come back
and do a second time or third time or
fourth time and they they
they view me as like some kind of
therapist angel down
yeah it's it's it's so many of the
people i've interviewed said they've
never shared these stories with anyone
and i know i mean i've had a handful of
people that came up to me and said you
know i haven't used my drugs since i've
talked to you
that was the best thing i ever did when
can i do it again
they don't want to be paid the second
time they just want to come back
well before we go much further i'd like
to play a clip so the audience can get
at least more of a taste of exactly
what's going on so um the first person
which i alluded to at the
at the outset of this uh show today
was this very arresting image of uh
jerry
who has uh half his face blown off he
has one remaining eye which doesn't
function fully um they've basically the
surgeons
uh through you know 24-hour periods of
surgery we were told
basically reformed skin he works he was
a machinist for uh
aerospace company coming home from work
at a bus stop
and he didn't even know he didn't see
anything happen he just next to you know
he woke up three months later in a
hospital
wow but somebody walked up to him with a
shotgun point blank and just shot him in
the side of the head
well let's uh let's hear him speak and
also at the same time it's interesting
that a part of the clip i want to show
is that he doesn't seem to have directed
animosity or hatred
amazingly let's play that clip here we
go i was sitting at a bus stop
going home from work one night a couple
months later i woke up in the hospital
i thought i was dreaming a doctor told
me
that i was sat inside his head with
saigon he said the only reason i
survived
because it was point blank range he said
it was not pointless
range but he was going down the streets
and see i can't see i got his left eye
on those i cannot smell or breathe at
all and just the skin here
you see your brains just hanging out
from out your head like a nice little
kid
hanging out in my face and said that's
remove it i'm gonna say something else
i haven't looked at myself over two
years things happen i just got accepted
you know
i keep moving on that was uh
quite astonishing to hear it's very
difficult sometimes to understand him
you
do use subtitles uh uh or capturing
uh captioning under your uh videos but
uh we use clips that we hope the
audience could could grasp
how did you read a little bit difficult
to understand how did you meet him
um i jerry pat was panhandling
uh right right near
right around the edge of skid row at the
flower mart
so that in the los angeles save this big
area that's nothing but uh
wholesalers selling to florist shops and
the general public can go there on
certain days and
and buy flowers for weddings or whatever
they want
and jerry uh would would panhandle there
he would just sit there with a tin can
and
shake it shake the money in his camp and
people would give him money
and it was the first time i saw him i
was just like
jesus this is the saddest thing i've
ever seen and when you approached him
and spoke to him
was he receptive i mean very friendly
yeah no i didn't in fact i
when i first walked out to him i told
him what i was doing and he said yeah
sure you want let's go right now i said
come on and i took him to my studio and
we talked in the car and we got very
he's very friendly he's just delightful
to talk to and and
he's a really sweet man super sweet yeah
and like
like like it's it's like he and i like i
show up and he just wants to talk
basketball he wants he loves to talk
about nba basketball
and he's just the friendliest kindest
person you have ever met you can feel it
when you're just in his presence
so mark i have to ask you about the
technical aspect so you've got me in
your studio
this is one of your first interviews
early on back in the day uh
you you've got you know uh your
diffusion set up and you decide to shoot
him
did you feel awkward or perhaps not i
mean
one doesn't have to feel this way did
you feel awkward if there was ever a
moment you felt i might be
exploiting someone if at all you
entertained that idea no i would imagine
that jerry would be the case with half
his face missing
no that that thought has never ever
entered my brain okay
one thing i learned i mean this is
interesting uh i was doing portraits in
new york city
uh i used to do them in all over the
country for create equal but then after
that i just started doing more and more
i was doing them in manhattan once
and i was with my assistant axel who was
worked with me for decades
and i was just picking up every all
kinds of interesting people in manhattan
and then manhattan has tons of
interesting characters on the street
right
and i would pick up whoever just was
interesting walking down the street
and ask someone tell them what i'm doing
and almost everyone would come upstairs
with me up to the sixth floor
of a building on broadway in uh near uh
union square my assistant goes it's
amazing how everybody
trusts you like everybody trusts you to
come upstairs all these
like like you know manhattan has some of
the most beautiful women in the world
and i would just
she might have an interesting story so i
would just walk up to her and
you know if i was if i was a guy looking
to date the girl
i might you know there'd be different
body language and my voice would get
tight or you know whatever
know yes things that happened like that
but in this case because
i knew subconsciously my motives were
pure yes
i knew that what i was doing was it was
a good thing for her and for me and for
everyone
so they read that people can sense that
and he says how are you getting the most
beautiful women on the planet to just go
up a sixth floor with you
you don't they don't even know who you
are and you're much bigger than i'm six
four so they're you're much bigger than
they are you could overpower them easily
and they they come up gladly i realized
that wow
what is that why is it if i was asking
her out for a phone number or something
it would probably play out differently
but because i'm doing this
they just like easily just agree and i
think it's because of that what i just
said which is
my i knew that what i'm doing
i'm honoring them and they can sense
that
right they can sense that i'm not up to
no good it just flows from there
well let's hear a female voice pamela a
more certainly more recent
person you interviewed uh pamela is a
prostitute uh
she reveals that she only went to the
seventh grade she was molested by an
uncle
uh witnessed a lot of violence uh
has at various times had to jump out of
vehicles and
horrifically saw her friend run over
and in this clip she talks about a
variety of things
you ask her about the most unusual type
of thing the client has asked her to do
and she she tells us uh you're listening
to watching america i'm your host dr
alan campbell my guest is mark later and
i must remind the audience that
this is an extremely mature program as
has been
forewarned at the outset of the show by
our producer
gina gamboni senior producer gina
gamboni if you are inclined to find
things offensive
um disturbing then i would strongly
recommend you don't listen to the
remainder of this program
but here we go now with uh the voice of
pamela as interviewed by mark
later 14 i got kidnapped
by a pimp this one guy is crush fetish
he just wanted me to step on a muffin
and
you know smash it in the sidewalk like
this
he gave me 800 to do that and my one of
my wife-in-laws got killed
and she got killed and i found her in
the middle of the street dead
and it like blew my mind so when i did
heroin
it numb me i didn't have to feel the
pain
i felt like i was back in my mother's
womb when we went back to pick her up
she was just laying in the middle of the
street dead
with her head busted open and like every
ounce of blood
drained out of her body i've had to jump
out of cars
i'm going 40 miles an hour 50 miles an
hour
i've been beat with clothes hangers i've
never seen my son
well i seen him when he was 10 months
old and my middle son
10 days old and my girl she was
10 months now some people would say
i understand i think why you do it but
some people say well why do you have to
ask questions about their daily routine
sex workers and you say um well first
off it's interesting
it's an interesting aspect of what they
do i mean i'm not sure i'm not
interviewing insurance agents talking
about how they you know shuffle papers
and
and work numbers all day i'm talking
with a prostitute and what they do is
sometimes
you're saying double indemnity isn't
interesting
i i just i just think these are these
are very interesting lifestyles that i'm
documenting
and and to not ask those questions kind
of leaves the whole thing like
oh anyway i still get people like oh i
wish you would answer this or i wish
you'd asked that
yes and and at some point you need to
feel out the subject and
figure out what you can get away with
and what's going to be disrespectful or
what's going to make them uneasy
um but with pamela she was and then most
people i interviewed they're pretty open
and
it's almost like they've never been
asked they've never shared these things
and
to be asked in this in this kind of
environment
is willing to share everything do you
feel ever depressed when you have
say you know and i was going to say a
young woman but a lot of older women too
who come off the street they've been
servicing customers
come right to you you know they're
drinking a sprite or whatever it is they
do their interview and you know they're
returning to that world
do you ever just want to reach out and
say ah how can i help this person what
can i do now i know that you have
actually
by your own estimation given about 150
000
away and invested in people um
how do you handle that when they when
they're going to descend the stairs from
your studio and you know they're going
to go right back to how they've lived
yeah i mean that's the case in almost
all
of the people i've talked to um it's a
really difficult situation and most
people i don't think
could could stomach it i think it just
gets
it can be so draining and so
you're just so defeated there's nothing
you could do to save this person if you
wanted to you would get taken down
before they're gonna get saved
if i was if i was totally going to help
someone you know
you end up you end up let's say you're
going to start
paying the rent or giving them money
they're just going to use the
excess money for for whatever their
their addiction is and you have to
understand
and i learned this in the first like
eight years of being down there shooting
down on skid row that
a lot of these people are not helpable
you can't help them
they're not even willing they're not
interested in being helped
even though they might say it in the
interview you know like a lot of people
saying oh i just i just want some help i
wish somebody would just do this for me
and do that
you have to understand that those are
words and it's almost like the way i see
it now
because i've taken some of those people
earlier on i'd be like oh my god you
just need this that and the other
so i would give them this that and the
other and that cost a lot of money
and i realized what i was doing is just
enabling them to continue doing what
they're doing
how do you differentiate between those
who are lying and those who are not
there are some cases
and it's a very interesting array of
videos just to remind the audience
you're listening to watching america i'm
dr alan campbell and mark later
uh is my guest he is a very successful
photographer
with uh studios on both coasts one
manhattan 1la
done a lot of commercial work for ibm
bmw for apple you name it he's done it
uh
high gloss high style photography it's
been the recipient of
awards has had private shows has written
three books created equal
c and serpentine and has his own
dedicated channel
on youtube which is called soft white
underbelly
on those shows mark on the segments you
will
sometimes say something to the effect of
and i'm paraphrasing
after years of hearing people speak um
i've learned to recognize
untruths and what have you and then
other persons that speak
you seem to be neutral and not sure and
accepting
how how have you learned or have you
learned in fact maybe it's a skill
that's never developed
to differentiate between the authentic
and those who are just simply going for
a sympathy
uh narrative yeah it's sometimes it
becomes hard to
decipher what is truth and what is made
up and i'm sure
you know it's just the nature of telling
a story if you and i were speaking about
our old school days and the teacher that
was a monster that we had when we were
in
eighth grade or whatever back in high
school uh
you embellish those stories and you make
the gym teacher seem more
more evil than he was and and the
you know every everything gets
exaggerated so there's plenty of that
going on with these stories
but there have been some where there's
this totally concocting
stories and and i've even been fooled a
few times i put up those stories and
then their
their parents contact me or their
siblings and say oh that's all
bs and i do a little homework and find
out that yes that that's
that's totally untrue and i delete the
video um
there's one or two there's one that i've
left up with an
ex explanation saying this is totally a
lie i've spoken to the family that's the
one i'm referring to yes
uh sarah i think sarah right um i lost
my daughters and my husband last summer
in a house fire
i've never been drunk um my husband got
really you know he stayed home he never
had a job in his life
he was using drugs i found out about
crystal meth he was slamming it
and actually slamming in his neck when i
caught him with drugs and a significant
amount of money i had around 140
000 in the bank and i was down to like
nine grand
and when i realized this um first time
ever he he was leaving me the longest
ever was six days he left me tied up in
the bathroom
and um he put he was putting cigarettes
out on me i have over 100 of them all
over my body
i had holes some of them took over a
year to even heal my
kids this year would have been 20 18
15 and 13. so and they just died last
summer
their father set their beds on fire
while they were asleep and i stabbed me
five times and he killed himself
she was just so like convincing that
that was like really it was the first
time i really got fooled and
you know maybe one day i'll delete it
but for now it's still up there no i
think it actually serves
a purpose if i may as an outsider say it
gives perspective and balance so it's
actually um
warranted well when people are signing
waivers
uh to allow you to uh use their imagery
don't you have a professional
problem in that many of these people are
using aliases to begin with
and they are highly spurious
questionable personalities so
how do you handle that well i mean uh
i i try to get id's but a lot of these
people don't have ids yeah
um and you just you know if somebody
comes back to me and says oh this is
a problem or whatever then i'll take the
video down that that that's happened
like once or twice
it hasn't really hasn't really come up
but but technically
i'm sure there's more than a handful of
cases where i'm putting up a video and
this
model release they signed is not really
their real name
and i don't think anybody's ever going
to come back to me and says hey that's
that's not
that wasn't me or that you know whatever
well i'm eager to lead
uh leave actually the the idea of people
faking you out but there's one story i
have to allude to which i'm sure you can
uh imagine is kelly do you have contact
with your mom or anybody
no viewers on your own i don't have
anybody
nobody but god that's why i have to sell
prostitute so get to get by and on the
county
that's all i have is the county in my
tent
and god and [ __ ]
tricks that's all i have
nobody checks on me nobody calls my
government phone i don't know who
my dad is
i just try to be strong because and i'm
just trying to get it together
because i i don't want to be out here
for the rest of my life
i really don't uh
you received criticism because you had a
great deal of empathy and sympathy for
her
and you set up a gofundme fund and your
intention was not to give her the money
to go back to school and to there was x
amount of dollars which i think was
around 9 000 or something like that
it ended up being 28 000. it wound up
being 28 000.
and and then there was some soothsayers
uh sitting at home
on the couches in their armchairs
watching the interview and saying there
are things here that don't add up
and then i believe it was the washington
post got involved and some others have
written about this
that it was then questionable about your
motivations
and then suddenly you looked at a
scansed with um
uh disfavor how did you handle that and
have you fully recovered from that whole
episode
yeah i mean my little joke is that none
of my videos are fully uploaded until
some commenter says they're
they're live
virtually every single video i put up
somebody comments oh these person's
lying
and the interesting thing about kelly
her real name is kiara but
you know here's what happened i post a
video every day pretty much sometimes
two a day
um and christmas eve i was shooting
down on skid row and this gang member
that i
know brought this his girlfriend i guess
and said you you want to talk to this
girl i'm like i was driving away with my
equipment i was leaving for the day and
i'm like see you later i'm gone
he goes no no you you talk to this girl
i look at her and she looks like she's
12 years old
i'm like all right so i pull over and
she tells me your story a little bit
just to give me a 30 second version i'm
like okay
let me back up and i'll sign up again
and we'll i'll shoot one more
and it turned out to be this really
heartbreaking story one of the one of
the most
powerful on my channel i would i would
say
and i edited it that night and i put it
up on christmas day i wasn't going to
put anything on christmas day because
my content is so dark i just figured it
wasn't appropriate but her story was
it was certainly dark but it was kind of
like i don't know beautiful at the same
time
so i put it up on christmas day the
morning
and it initially got a really strong
reaction people were heartbroken over
her story
and then she calls me back like four or
five days later and says you know can
you take it down my family's giving me a
hard time
and i'm like okay sure so i deleted her
video even though it was great
and then two more three two three weeks
later she calls me up and says you know
what
forget my family my family's never done
anything for me they've never been there
for me
put the video back up just just use my
street name because
originally i posted the video with her
real name which is kiera
and uh she said use my street name which
is kelly so i put it up the second time
with
kelly and i got to know this girl by
then i saw that
you know she was working figaro street
which is the street in los angeles where
all the prostitutes i mean like
unbelievable
amount of prostitution going on on that
street yeah so she has a
she has the arrest records you know all
the girls down there know her so
there's no doubt that she was a
prostitute um she claims that
she never went to high school but you
know the the washington post
reporter looked up the fact that she had
registered for high school but then
kiara says that she uh she did register
for high school but she never went she
went for like two days and then never
never went so and she was in the foster
system she said she was at six years
old and the uh washington post said it
was five years old so her
parts of her story are not 100 proven
but whether she went to high school or
didn't doesn't matter whether she was
in the foster system at five years old
or six years old it doesn't matter
the fact that this girl was working
figaro street as a prostitute getting
arrested
living that super dangerous lifestyle
and a fairly lucrative lifestyle i mean
these girls say they make
you know five hundred to a thousand
dollars or more a day a night
and everyone says they're lying but but
i believe that those numbers aren't
they're exaggerated i'm sure but they're
not greatly exaggerated they're not
making
75 a night they're making easily
several hundred dollars a night and a
lot more for some
she um she gave that up
she chose as a 22 year old girl to give
that
up and and just try to start a new life
without anyone's help
no family no nothing no money you know
she yes she had braces yes she had
fingernails yes she had nice clothes
because that's what these girls have
they all have that if you look at all
these girls they all have nice hair and
nice clothes and
fingernails and all that because they
make good money um
tax-free and so she gave that all up to
start a new life at 22 years old
without an education and that's
remarkable and i saw that she was doing
this i saw that she wasn't going back to
her old ways after those
after i took the video down and then
before i put it back up so when i decide
when she told me i could put it back up
i said you know what this person
deserves some help i'm going to try this
gofundme thing i heard about it and i'm
like i'm going to try my first gofundme
with this girl so i posted her video
with a link to the gofundme and in two
days it generated
twenty eight thousand twenty nine i
think gofundme takes a percentage so
twenty nine thousand dollars in two days
it was actually thirty thousand
but but what happened is
on that second time the video got
uploaded again i got lots of views and
lots of empathetic compassionate
concerned commenters as soon as the word
got out that her gofundme was a wild
success
then all of a sudden everything flipped
and all these comments saying she was
lying it's all made up it's all whatever
here's a picture of her mom's facebook
with her and her mom here's a picture of
her grandmother with her and it's like
you know
it's all a lie and you know she's
getting a nice break that no one else is
getting right
so i think that created this
all these claims of her story being
being fake
because if if i'd never done a gofundme
for her her story is identical to
everyone else's
on my channel if you watch all the
prostitute videos they're all basically
the same exact story
there's some details that are changed
you know one worked with a pimp when she
was
14 years old and the other one met a
pimp when she was 16 and one
you know little detailed difference the
typical scenario seems to be you know
very often there's a mother or father
have substance abuse
there's uh a a menacing uncle or father
that
physically abuses them they run away
they drink a lot they do weed then they
progress to something else then they get
caught
up in the system they go work for a a
pimp then they go into a foster home
then they're out of there again
i had a personal experience i wasn't
planning on sharing this but i will
right now
i when i lived in san francisco i lived
there for 11 years uh
and i came in contact was brought to my
attention a young woman who was a
prostitute she was a heroin addict
and um i was very very grieved
by seeing this she had track marks and
and everything was working and she had a
pimp
she finally wound up in san francisco
city hospital
and in many locations you don't want to
be in the city hospital
i went and saw her um and i said if
i were to be able to find a way for you
to get and be able to kick this
would you really be willing to do that
she said yes
i worked fervently pulling every contact
i had
in san francisco and i managed to find
one of the best
clean up facilities drug addiction
facilities
in in the bay area i got her
at the top of the list i mean she they
do because of
a good reputation i had for various
things i got her at the top of the list
i arranged with another person because i
wasn't going to drive her by myself i
arranged with another person to go and
pick her up
and to take her immediately there for
when she was going to be discharged
i went to the hospital i was elated i
thought this is it i'm going to make a
change in this girl's life
you probably can anticipate what
happened i got there
and she had walked and her pimp had come
in early in the wee hours of the morning
and escorted her out
um it is so disheartening and that's
just one incident
you have had hundreds and hundreds like
this how do you keep going
well to me what i'm doing is not about i
mean it sounds cold but
i'm not about helping these individuals
i've helped more than my share
you know as you've mentioned i've spent
well over a hundred thousand dollars
helping so and so and doing things
exactly like what you just described
and that costs money you put somebody up
in a hotel for two months
yeah that adds up when you want to get
them
transportation to go you know wherever
they're going
the the money that i believe doing this
is is insane it's embarrassing my
accountant goes what the hell are you
doing
because i'm not getting receipts for any
you know
for most of what i'm doing there are no
receipts um
but rather than saying i'm going to help
each and every individual of the 2000
and more that i've
interviewed i can't do that one person
can't do that
but honestly what i'm trying to do is
help people understand have some
awareness
and and see what's really going on and
see how these things happen
so that we can prevent it for the next
generation i mean what's that great
quote uh
it's easier to raise strong children
than to repair broken men
yeah i think frederick douglass quote
yes good quote
it's a great quote yeah because you want
to fix these people
the the problem is not that they have a
drug addiction it looks like oh these
are people are drug addicts or they're
or there's uh sex work addicts or
they're
gang members or whatever the problem is
that they never were loved as children
they've never experienced unconditional
love and that is the problem
because you fix the addiction you give
them a house you give them a car you
give them a job you give them everything
they need
and they'll be back to where they
started because they still are trying to
numb the pain of never being loved
the way to fix that is prevent it from
happening in the next generation
when you're dealing with people who are
clearly delusional i'm thinking of sweet
pea i'll play a clip from sweet pea
it's my first time for having a pimp a
financial advisor whatever
i give him all my money whatever i need
he gets it from me so
yeah i wouldn't be doing it at all if i
didn't have my pimp
or my daddy making money is making money
at the end of the day you look at it
i mean i'm in love with my pen i do love
him
um she speaks of her pimp as being her
financial
advisor yeah they all call them those
financial advisors
and and her pimp is her daddy pimp um
it's very interesting usage of
professional lingo for
financial advisor and then familiar
terminology
for her daddy pimp when very often daddy
in real life was the problem
um do you ever just want to just say to
people like okay
listen to what you're saying sweetheart
listening to the incongruency of what
you said
but i did that a little bit on that
interview just because she was so
closed off to reality being aware of
what she was doing and
and not looking at and it's like so i
got a little bit
judgmental which i've never really done
on my videos but i kind of did a little
bit of that
on that one just because she's asking
for it she's just like so in denial of
anything that she was doing
i mean she's got a kid she's addicted to
drugs i think fentanyl i think it was
yes um and she's got a pimp that she's
been in love with for two weeks
and and he's managing her money hundred
percent of it it's like oh come on
come on everything is wrong here and
i've i
i think i said something kind of
indicating that
can you not look at this and see it more
clearly but you know she she can't
i'd like to talk about the artistry
because i think we would be remiss if we
don't acknowledge the artistry to what
you do
you have developed an aesthetic uh the
opening is we hear street sounds very
often
uh ambient street sounds then we hear a
voice of the person who's about to be
interviewed
then you dissolve into um titles black
and white
um white over black and then it
dissolves again and then we have a color
image of somebody speaking
and then eventually at some strategic
point you would then go to your portrait
that you've done
you typically will start at the top with
the face and you basically tilt down
uh i presume you've taken the picture
with a large format camera
and then you tilt down so you can get
the clarity because you can't
do a horizontal plane but it works and
it's an aesthetic that the viewer comes
to expect
did that come innately to you or is it
something you you
meditate it's really just a terrible
compromise because
i'm shooting these very vertical
portraits yes you know i had a 9 by 13
inch camera custom made so it would
basically accommodate the shape of a
human body
the dimensions you know that's right
versus the width and
there is no way on social media which is
our new world now
to display a tall of a tall vertical
yes you know instagram is basically
square and so is everything else and
and youtube is horizontal and since i'm
doing video uh interviews now the videos
those are horizontal so it's like how do
you fit a long a kind of almost
extremely long vertical
into a horizontal format right you just
don't put it sideways
so the best thing i can come up with is
this terrible compromise where i pan
down the portrait and it's it's
i cringe every time i do it but there is
no other way but i think there's a good
effect to it because very often i mean
i'm not trying to be unkind i'm just
being realistic as you are
very often you'll see significant
details as you begin to tilt down you
begin to notice
uh scabs and cuts and dirty
toenails and the idea that the the
concept behind
all of this is to have like a an either
shot in such a large form a large
resolution that yes you know my idea was
to print like 12 or 15 foot tall
portraits
in a gigantic space and then have a
large
tv monitor playing the video alongside
that giant portrait
so the portrait is really the star the
portrait is what these are really all
about and the video is just a supplement
to the portrait
but i think what people have gotten used
to on youtube is the interviews
everything
and the portrait's disposable you don't
have to look at it
i've heard i've seen people comment like
what was that stupid portrait in there
for
it's like so to me it's really about the
portrait and the video is just
kind of like a back story to that
portrait
you did a a self-disclosure video
in fact you may have done two but i've
certainly seen one where you explain
what the the whole premise behind soft
white underbelly is
i noticed that you seemed uncomfortable
mark if i pointed out looking into the
camera directly you would do it
sporadically
but most of the time your eyes would
wander around your studio and then you
would look for something
i'm not a i'm not a i don't like being
in front of the camera that's not my
thing
and why is that why why don't like i
have two daughters
one is like me really uncomfortable in
front of a camera and the other one
is just um she's meant like my mom was a
model my ex-wife was a model so
she has it in her blood and she's
certainly picked up those jeans and
she's just
amazing in front of a camera like every
frame is beautiful
and my other daughter is the opposite of
that and i probably you know she takes
after me so i'm just not comfortable in
front of a camera but
i got through it mark later i'm very
cognizant
of obviously americans in america and
that's why this show is called watching
america
but i'm incredibly intrigued and
rewarded when i think about the persons
that make the fabric of this nation
particularly persons who do important
work and you do important work
i am so grateful to you for presenting
jerry to me and millions of other
viewers
and persons like jerry sarah for all of
her complexity
uh chiara or kelly whichever you prefer
sweet pea
and hundreds and hundreds and hundreds
of people more
you strike me as a person who is not at
ease
perhaps with praise or being lorded with
with recognition but i hope that you
will amend that for the next
10 seconds as i say that i think you are
truly an artist
and your life has purpose and meaning
in its own right but beyond that for
what you do and what you're bringing to
america's attention we may not have an
immediate panacea for what you
portray and present to us but indeed you
do awaken things in us that otherwise
should not have gone
unawoken and i want to thank you for
that so much
it's been a delight talking to you mark
here
take care sir and god bless thank you
bye-bye
watching america is a production of whrv
public media
in norfolk virginia